So I got a story to tell you that you
might like,
because I've thought a lot about that
use of language,
you know,
because language can be used as
camouflage.
And so here's the story.
I think I got this from Robert Sapolsky,
so he was talking about zebras and
zebras of course have stripes and
hypothetically that's associated with
camouflage,
but it's not a straightforward
association because zebras are black and
white and they're on the velt along with
the lions.
The lions are camouflage because their
grasp colored.
But the bloody zebras are black and
white.
You can see them like 15 miles away.
So okay.
So biologists go out to study zebras and
they're like making notes on a zebra and
they watch it and then they look down at
their notes and then they look up and
they think,
oh no,
I don't know which Zebra I was looking
at.
So the camouflage is actually against
the herd because the zebras,
a herd animal,
not an individual.
And so the black and white stripes
breakup the animal against the herd so
you can't identify it.
So this was a quandary for the
biologists.
So they did one of two things,
one was drive a jeep up to the,
to the zebra,
heard and use a dab of red paint and Dab
the horn.
Should the zebra or tag it with an ear
tag like used for cattle.
The lions would kill it.
So as soon as it became identifiable the
Predator,
yes,
the predators could organize their hunt
around that.
Identify all about animal.
That's why you know there's the old idea
that lions and predators take down the
weak animals,
but they don't.
They take down the identifiable animals.
So that's the thing is if you stick your
damn head up,
you get picked off by predators.
And so one of the things that academics
seem to do is congregate together in
heard like entities and then they share
a language,
right?
And the language unites them and also
keeps them.
As long as they share the same set of
linguistic tools among themselves there,
they know that there isn't anybody in
the,
in the codery that's going to attack
them or deed destabilize the entire
herd.
And that seems to me to account for that
impenetrable use of language.
It's,
it's,
it's group protection strategy and it
has absolutely nothing to do with the
search for.
It's the search for security within a
system and not the desire to expand the
system.